Gregg always great to talk with you the
guys came up with an interesting poll
question I haven't even chimed in on
myself yet well let's just say we're
gonna get to this for the first time but
I appreciate you mentioning the matchup
so I'm really excited about it I Luis
Riddick I'm sure you've been around him
a little bit he's really really smart
really gonna be fun working with him and
of course help ourselves out exactly
it's gonna be awesome and I think a lot
of people already do DVR but if you
haven't ever watched it because it's on
early on Sunday it's it I always call it
the show that the pros watch because I
know a lot of players and coaches end up
watching that when they're on one very
quick story I won't mention any names
just because it's not necessary but
sometimes when I'm watching pregame
shows on Sunday morning I hear the exact
phrases that we use on the matchup show
so I know that it's being watched by the
people who do the sunday pregame shows
yep that doesn't surprise me at all Greg
hey let's get to the poll question
though before I get into the night's
game a little bit with you I don't know
if it was Pauly or McLovin that came up
with it but the question is if let's
just say you were starting a team or
there's an expansion franchise and you
could get the best quarterback in the
NFL or the best head coach or the best
GM which one would you pick we would
basically would you pick Aaron Rodgers
or Belichick because there's so many
variables okay like let me give you a
quick story okay dad that place to your
question okay I was fortunate enough to
know Bill walls pretty well so he
coached Dan Fouts in 1976 as the
offensive coordinator in San Diego then
of course he coached Joe Montana so he
told me that there were certain routes
that he didn't use with Joe Montana that
he used with Dan Fouts because he said
Joe didn't make those throws real well
and Dan Fouts did so now most people
would think oh my god it's Joe Montana
he's the best quarterback ever or the
second-best you know whatever you think
a brady so you know so there's coaching
at its highest level you know so
it's such a difficult question because
there's so many variables you know when
a quarterback is great you know do we
automatically assume that he's great
under any circumstance no matter what
would happen right but for our
discussion I'm not asking you any
variables I'm just saying you stall that
team
that's a called question I mean you know
you know sometimes quarterbacks don't
make it for a lot of reasons and they
have a ton of talent
sometimes quarterbacks who don't
necessarily have a ton of what we would
call great traits or attributes make it
and become great you know as someone
like Drew Brees without without maybe
someone like Sean Payton if Drew Brees
you know was coached by someone else
with Drew Brees be Drew Brees you know
it's easy to say that now because we
have access to the results of his career
you know but would that have been the
case you know in a different scenario
okay so then let's just say guys we
already know let's just say Bill
Belichick or Aaron Rodgers for the next
ten years who would you rather have I
would answer that would and say probably
Bill Belichick yeah I can see that
especially because you know just
thinking of Greg what if Aaron Rodgers
gets hurt like players can get hurt
coaches aren't gonna get hurt right so
III think that that's an interesting
question that actually goes back alleys
debate a great question to have fun with
and I know people like lists I just
think for someone like myself who sits
in studies tape all day and then knows
the variables as you know as well but I
mean you know these are fun questions to
just throw around but you know there's
no to me there's no definitive answer
it's still a fun question what do you
think let's talk tonight and let's start
with the Patriots no Julian Edelman what
do you think the impact of that will be
on the Patriots offense and how do you
think they'll make up for his loss you
know I think there'll be some impact and
it might not be totally discernable only
because I think they have some other
players who can theoretically do what he
does fortunately they still have
Amendola
you know I think over time let me answer
it this way I think over time as this
year progresses and I think you saw it a
little bit toward the end of last year
when they didn't have cooks and didn't
have Dorsett I think you'll see a little
more vertical element to the pass game
as I said it started a little last year
Hogan was the beneficiary at times the
last time they were really vertical in
any meaningful way was with Randy Moss
but I think you'll see that a little
more just because now the players at
wide receiver will allow them to at
least build some of that into their
office do you think that Greg explains
them trading for Brandon cooks and and
more recently trading for Phillip
Dorsett it seems like you know they were
the first one to really focus on the
slot receiver is the middle of the field
is this another example of the Patriots
kind of zigging while everybody else
zagging getting these two threats no I
think it's dimensions Bilbao checks a
whole hell of a lot smarter than I am
obviously but you know I think it comes
down to dimensions within an offense I
mean at Brady's great no question Brady
wins before the ball snapped
he has phenomenal rapport with veteran
receivers alike Edelman who is now not
there where they can they can make
decisions in a split second after the
ball snap with so many of their choice
routes and option routes but I think
that every coach would like every
dimension that you can have on an
offense and that you could argue that
the dimension they didn't have Hogan
gave it to them to some degree later in
the season but certainly cooks and
theoretically door said if he can
acclimate quickly our true vertical guys
they give you a vertical dimension which
theoretically they didn't have talking
with Greg Cassell he's a buddy of mine
get a chance to talk to him each and
every week he is longtime NFL Films guru
and for the first time this year you're
gonna see him on the tube on ESPN NFL
matchup show he's been the executive
producer forever since the inception of
the show but now you can see him on TV
with Sal pal Antonio and Luis right
Saturdays and Sundays check your local
listings ESPN espn2 all over that let's
go to the other side gray and talk about
the Chiefs a little bit Tyree kill you
know when yeah when the Chiefs moved on
from Jeremy Maclin I felt like they were
telling us something significant about
Tyree kill is there a player that you
can give us a comparison of I think the
Chiefs think Tyree Keogh can be this guy
well we get to this the same question of
dimensions Tyree KL is truly explosive
he's explosive vertically Andy Reid in
his career Ross has not been that much
about isolation routes on the perimeter
four wide receivers where they just win
one-on-one he's been a lot more about
route concepts and combinations and
he'll may give them the opportunity
where he can line up that receiver on
the outside at times and he can win
number one but number two he forces a
defense to respond to him with help over
the top which opens up other areas of
the field because Travis Kelce may be
the most multi-dimensional receiving
tight end in the league right now so you
know I think that again it comes back to
that same word dimensions now you have
an explosive guy who on the black board
you know as a distraught Jackson type of
player I'm sure they're hoping he
developed into that kind of player in
their pass game so obviously he's a good
player Greg I'm just curious
with him at least playing on Sunday
night let's get to the Giants and the
Cowboys a little bit how much of a
difference do you think Zeke Elliott
makes over the backups there in Dallas
McFadden and the guys when you watch the
tape you know that's a really tough
question I mean you know two years ago
DeMarco Murray gained 18 hundred and
forty-five yards the year after that
McFadden in 12 starts gain about a
thousand and fifty yards they've got the
best offensive line in football you
could argue that Smith is the best best
left tackle in the game you can argue
that Martin is the best right guard in
the game Fred
is up there as potentially the best
center in the game so they have a
dominant offensive line normally if you
have a back that has any kind of ability
and you're committed to the run with a
great old line you will gain yards
running the football you know that Ross
I mean you're you're an old offensive
lineman and I mean all old and the
nicest way you know but so you know
they'll gain yards running the football
you know I spent a lot of time watching
the Cowboys off this offseason and one
thing that to me really stood out about
Zeke Elliott is how good he was in pass
protection he was very aware of fronts
and pressures he was a physical
aggressive pass protector you know he's
obviously a very good runner that's not
the point but he was a really good and
pass protection so I know Greg that you
get excited to watch the tape I mean you
get excited to go in there Monday and
unpack it and watch is there a player or
team that you're especially intrigued to
watch this Julie you just can't wait to
watch this player every week or this
team every week you know I would say one
team that fits into that category for me
as Tennessee because I think that under
Mike Mularkey they have a clear defined
approach as to how they want to play I
you know last year a lot of people might
not be aware but they had an eight or
nine game stretch where they averaged
over 30 points per game and I don't
think people think of him that way
and yet they went out and drafted Corey
Davis whose health is coming back and I
think will be a situational player this
week they drafted a one Taylor in the
third round so they're looking to keep
expanding their explosive playability
I think Mariota is an improving player
and I think if they can get some quality
corner play and that's a question mark I
think their defense can be really solid
so to me they're a team that's building
the right way and I don't know if this
is the year they're truly ready but I
think to me they're a fascinating team
to watch I know you like watching all of
them Greg but out of the rookie
quarterbacks forget Kaiser because we
know he's starting but out of the three
guys that aren't starting true Biscay
mahomes Watson who who are you most
looking forward to when they get a
chance to actually get some regular sees
and starts under their belt well I would
say the player that most intrigues me
and there's so many elements to him in
so many variables is mahomes because of
his pure arm talent but he's a guy that
needs an awful lot of work because
there's he's so lacking in his
fundamentals and his understanding which
is coaching so it's all a matter of when
it comes if it comes
but clearly just you know for someone
who believes in armed talent and
believes in arm strength at the NFL
level mahomes is fascinating and
intriguing guy to watch well you're an
intriguing listen Greg every time I get
a chance to talk with you each and every
week thanks so much for coming on the
show preciate a lot thanks for having me
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience